President Trump this morning tweeted
that new talks between North and South
Korea are a good thing and suggested his
tough stance against North Korea made
them possible this week mr. Trump
tweeted that his nuclear button is much
bigger and more powerful than Kim Jong
Un's for 60 minutes in 2016 David Martin
visited the military command center
responsible for any action if the
president orders a nuclear strike he's
at the Pentagon with what must happen
before a nuclear conflict erupts between
the u.s. and North Korea David good
morning good morning it's much more
complicated than simply pushing a button
but president Trump's tweet that his
nuclear button is bigger and more
powerful than Kim Jong Un's is not an
empty boast this one nuclear-powered
submarine which 60 minutes went aboard
in the Pacific can carry more nuclear
warheads than Kim jong-un has in his
entire arsenal commander Brian Freck was
the captain of the USS Kentucky the
warheads that can be carried on my
missiles are extremely powerful and
compare them to the bomb that level of
Hiroshima much more powerful than than
that much more powerful than Hiroshima
Freck and his crew along with nuclear
bombers and intercontinental ballistic
missiles are at the tip of a chain of
command which leads all the way back to
the president who was never far from a
briefcase called the football inside or
the code opposition to fire needed to
order the launch of nuclear weapons the
order would go to the commander of the
US Strategic Command so who in the
United States government has the
authority to order the use of nuclear
weapons only the president of the United
States has that authority does Congress
have to approve no Congress does not
have to approve so these really are the
president's own weapons
it's our nation's weapons with the
president's authority yes Admiral Cecil
Haney is now retired replaced by General
John heighten who last year told a
conference he would not carry out an
order to use nuclear weapons if he
thought it was unnecessary I'm gonna say
mr. president say illegal and guess what
he's going to do he's going to say what
would be legal and we'll come up with
options of a mix of capabilities to
respond to whatever the situation is and
that
the way it works American policy is to
use nuclear weapons only in extreme
circumstances such as a nuclear attack
on the US last fall Tom Boyd one of the
Pentagon's top missile analysts told 60
minutes Kim jong-un has more work to do
before he has a weapon that can deliver
a nuclear warhead to the American
homeland probably several more flight
tests but ultimately if they want to
have confidence that the system works as
intended they have to flight test it and
prove that that reentry vehicle can
survive realistic re-entry conditions
u.s. intelligence estimates that that
happened as early as this year if and
when it does two nuclear-armed countries
headed by two unpredictable leaders will
be on a collision course Nora
David let me ask you so if one of the
presidents top advisors like his chief
of staff general Kelly or general
McMaster his national security adviser
opposed the president in launching
nuclear weapon would they have any say
to do that or power to do that they're
not in the chain of command for ordering
the use of nuclear weapons it goes it
goes from the President to the Secretary
of Defense to the head of US Strategic
Command they can offer advice but they
they can't interpose themselves in that
chain of command and ultimately the
president has the launch codes the
president has the launch codes and he
has he carries a little card with him
called the biskits which carries another
code which identifies him as the
president so it's not simply the sound
of his voice that gives the order but
it's him identifying himself through
that authentication code all right David
thank you so much it is interesting and
you've heard Congress essentially for
the first time since the Cold War
debating essentially that chain of
command and how it gets carried out
there's more on that is an extraordinary
moment in terms of the American
presidency